uh we're expecting a very big yes vote
um i think we'll easily break the
thresholds uh the government and i would
expect to get 90 percent excess of that
vote in uh in favor
and as i we always say the objective is
not to have a strike it's to reach a
settlement and but the background to
this is that the company have made
record profits for the second year
running 758 million pounds
they've paid 400 million pounds to
shareholders uh and at the same time as
the ceo and the board have decided to
impose a two percent
uh pay increase on workers uh they're
getting bonuses in the region of 140 000
pounds so by any level of fairness this
is completely unacceptable when they're
treating the workforce without a
contempt
what is it that you want
we want a good settlement um
i mean well we want a settlement that
protects our members against the current
cost of living crisis that rewards their
efforts
uh during the pandemic these were key
workers done a fantastic job to keep
this company going
and you know what they've put on the
table at the moment is unacceptable in
terms of the level of that i mean i hear
these debates about you know unions are
asking for
figures that are going to spiral
inflation
um you know
it's not true you know workers aren't
going to get 12 13 14 pay rises but
there's a huge gap between what's on
offer here and what these companies can
afford and we're going to get the very
best deal we can for our members what do
you want
well i've just told you what we want i'm
not here negotiating well you know we no
no no let me say the doctors want one
sold 30 percent over uh five years we
know that barristers want 25 we have
other percentage figures as well why is
it not reasonable to ask you well
because
what i'm saying is you know that's a
matter for negotiation and our members
will back the union we want
to match inflation if we can achieve
that but you know i'm going to be honest
with you i mean the company keeps saying
that they've offered five and a half
percent well that's not true
um they've imposed two percent five and
a half percent is never going to be
acceptable these are matters for
negotiation the company has got to come
to the table with a substantially
improved offer
and they can afford it would 11 be
enough i mean because that would that's
what we're expecting inflation to be
absolutely
well it would certainly be something
that we'd go back and talk to our
members about wouldn't it okay but that
would just be standing still
well look we understand uh the realities
of the situation
but employers need to understand that
you know you can't carry on
with this agenda of leveling a doubt
leveling down the workforce and it's
happening not just in role models
happening in other industries
where we represent members right across
the uk and it is a leveling down agenda
and i think it's so unfair at the moment
that every time workers decide to do
something
about the situation and they come
together in their collective strength
that somehow we're in the wrong and
we're not and i don't think people are
going to put up
with the unfairness that's going on with
the imbalance of power and wealth that
permeates the world of work the economy
and all of the growing inequalities in
society i think people decide it's
turning
um
how do you feel about coordinated strike
action
um well look i think you do whatever is
necessary to increase the pressure on
the employer um and to achieve the best
deal and but at the end of it you know
our focus will be on our dispute what is
happening is co-donation is there's a
campaign that's running alongside this
it's going to continue
beyond uh these particular uh pay
disputes that are taking place across
the uk at the moment and that's called a
campaign for a new deal for workers and
a new social settlement in the uk it's
being led by trade unions what does it
mean it means shifting the balance of
forces in the world of work so it means
starting to get proper jobs uh you know
not relying on uh these insecure
employment models that are dragging the
whole nation down
um it means leveling up creating a race
to the top it's the real leveling up
agenda it means empowering workers to
have more say over how their companies
are run and it's also got a social
element to it so we want to kind of make
sure that we rebuild the services start
looking after the workers there's so
much money that keeps being spoken about
by governments politicians from all
persuasions about this is what you've
got to put in we want to see some of
that money coming back to work ordinary
working people they deserve it they're
what keeps the economy going and you
know we're going to run this campaign so
you know i just want to make this point
i'll keep hearing the summer of this
content yeah well i'm also going to ask
you we're going beyonce
i'm about to ask you what your strike
action would look like because they were
almost out our strike action would
obviously affect all of the services uh
in royal mail we've got a similar
balance that the results of which will
be announced on thursday in british
telecom various parts of british telecom
it'll be the first time
that we've had ballots for strike action
across the whole of the membership that
we pretty much represent so yeah it's
going to have an impact but i repeat our
objective is to reach a settlement not
have a strike okay good to talk to you
thank you for coming in much appreciated